welcome back to cbs this morning we're
learning new details this morning about
comedian jay farrell's
disturbing encounter with los angeles
police in april
now the surveillance video shows lapd
officers
running toward him with their guns drawn
they ordered the former saturday night
live star to the ground
and then handcuffed him farrell says one
officer placed a knee on his neck
police reportedly told him that he
matched the description of a suspect
pharaoh who was released a short time
later says he was scared
confused and the victim of racism
i'm walking across the street and then
all of a sudden i hear get on the ground
the cop from the left of me he's just
he's coming he's got his gun out
i don't know what's happening but you
didn't think they were talking to you at
first
did you you did i didn't because because
gail like i said i'm
i i don't have any run-ins with the law
i've never even had a ticket
i've never had guns pointed at me girl
i've never had a handcuffs put on me
so they tell you to get on the ground do
you immediately comply
they said lay on the ground and spread
your arms out
like an airplane the officer comes he
gets on top of me he puts his
knee on me he puts my hands my my arms
are back here
he puts on the cuffs i'm shocked i'm
scared i don't know why i'm being
detained
i'm just totally confused right now so
they pulled me
up telling me that i fit the description
what was the description the description
was
a black man in gray sweatpants
and a gray shirt did you have on a gray
sweatpants and a gray t-shirt
oh yeah i did i do so what should they
have done i think the right way to
handle the situation would have been for
the cops
to calmly come up to me since they see i
don't have anything on me it should have
been like
hey man we having a problem right now
they ask you
if you have your id because there's
somebody who just
who just ran fled the scene from from
police officers
and we're looking for him the officer
kneel where did he kneel on you
the cop put his he put his pressure he
put all it is this is his his knee is
right his knee his knee his leg right
here
on your neck is on your neck it was
right here on the bottom of my neck
this is before the george floyd case so
in that moment
what were you thinking when he had his
knee on your neck
i just thought why now i do not have
eight minutes and 46 seconds of an
officer being on top of me like that
obstructing my airway and choking me i
don't have that
luckily they pulled me up and i got out
of it
but it's like why does it have to
go to that extremity when i'm an
innocent bystander we should never have
to feel
like our lives are in danger when we're
doing regular
human activities i don't want to have
the fear for my life
when i'm going to whole foods and
getting some getting some chips and guac
or picking up a kombucha it's the
assumption that bothers you it doesn't
seem
like you were given the benefit of the
doubt doesn't it that's the thing
gail black people in america
in general why do we have to feel like
we're guilty
until proven innocent where the other
side
gets innocent until proven guilty i saw
a video yesterday
where there was a um gentleman and uh
the cop was trying to apprehend him
the guy ran at him the cop starts
running
he's running the suspect then
gets in the car backs out and almost
hits the police officer
any shots fired no shots fired
whatsoever
when you said that you were scared did
you worry that you could lose your life
yes when i see guns coming towards me
my natural instinct is all snap yeah
i could i could die you said you were
complying did you say my name is
i said i don't have my id on me but if
you google jay farrell you will see that
you're making a serious mistake
a couple of minutes later they came back
and they said oh we got a call that
you're not the guy
sorry my bad my bad
is it jj did they say my bad did they
say that
they said i'm oh sorry sorry
that's not enough there needs to be some
practice
with this policing reform i don't want
to see another 20 black people be
martyrs
for no reason who was the first person
you called after this happened to you
i called my mom and i told her what
happened my dad was on the phone too and
it just um
you know uh my mom started crying and
that affects you too to see your family
crying too
it's a terrible feeling that the the
aftermath of such a
such a terrible situation can cause that
much impact on people around you i hit
up steve harvey when it happened
he said you gotta be in black and
american sandwich and i said that's
exactly
i've eaten it and i know how it tastes
being black in america's sandwich yeah
yeah and it don't taste good you know
what tastes good
what just being a beautiful black person
just being you yes
that feels good too
well we reached out to the los angeles
police department they said quote we are
aware of this video it's under
investigation jay pharaoh is a comedian
so he still has a sense of humor but
make no mistake this was very uh
shocking and very jarring to him because
tony
it started he's on an app an exercise
app that tells you to run stop
run stop this happened when he was
stopped and they came at him with
you know guns drawn he said suppose i'd
had my earphones on which i did
with my music blaring and i was running
i would never even have heard them i
wouldn't even heard them or seen them
until it was way too late so it's been a
very difficult time this happened also
back in april
and i said why are you releasing it now
he said he didn't want to release it in
the middle of george floyd and mod
rberry because he didn't want to appear
that
he was trying to take anything away from
the moment but many friends said to him
you should tell this story and i'm
really glad he did i think it's
important for people to see
how this happens and how quickly it
could go from
zero to deadly it didn't happen in this
case but how quickly things can escalate
well yeah i i think it's a good thing he
released the video because we're talking
about police reform now and there's so
many opportunities for
reform that come up in that video i mean
suppose for a second that he wasn't jay
pharaoh that he's not someone you can
google
and he's just out for a run and he
doesn't have his id would he go all the
way to jail
he's he be facing fives and fees that's
the question also
is black man and gray sweatpants really
a good enough description to use to go
guns out on somebody and i think that's
the question
and and i think tony you had a better
even if you even if you had a better
description
and you come up on somebody is the
training really necessary to have the
weapon drawn
for that to be the first point of
contact not as he said
hey we're having an issue can you show
us an id maybe answer a couple questions
we've got to check something out
i think those are all questions that
really come back to the conversation
right now which is
how do we make this better how do we
train police to interact
differently and maybe get different
outcomes